Shane mcCormick wrote in and said please
read this at the next Babylon he or she
insisted Shane's one of those names you
don't know which way you're going with
okay so I thought I would read it it's
tiny Prince I'm gonna need my reading
glasses actually but this is the
greatest thing I ever read it is you can
now go on Amazon and you go to Amazon
Prime and you can watch the shape of
water oscar-winning film the shape of
water is now available for your viewing
pleasure at Amazon did you see it I have
seen it I have seen I've seen it yes
I'll Mick Jagger and I've seen it it
sounded more southern twang to me like I
have seen it in Dallas what is uh I've
seen it and loved it yes it's miss
gentleman not so much oh really I want
to read you this is one of the early
reviews of Amazon videos version of the
shape of water can we put that up there
Josh as I read along I wish I could give
this thing 0 stars you don't see the
fishes dick not once how is such a thing
possible
let's make Jurassic Park but not show
the dinosaurs let's make aliens but no
Xenomorphs how about a how about Titanic
with zero boat this is a movie about a
lady having sex with a fish who has a
fish penis and the fact that you never
get to lay eyes upon his aquatic member
is an embarrassment to everyone involved
would love to say I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed but I'm definitely both
let's picture my ass anyone who says
they like this pile needs to take a look
in the mirror and tell themselves they
deserve better than a movie about a
woman who has sex with a fish where you
never see the fishes dick not once
the greatest movie review I've ever read
I am shocked that you found my review I
saw somebody on Twitter referred to the
shape of water is grinding Nemo
it's pretty good it's pretty good line
right there
[Music]
you
[Music]